Firebase is an app development
platform from Google that offers
tools and services for building
and scaling applications. It
includes real time databases,
authentication, analytics, and
hosting features. In this
course, you will learn how to
build a mobile app with HTML,
CSS, JavaScript, and Google
Firebase.
Hey there lovely freeCodeCampers and welcome to my fully
interactive Scrimba Firebase
course. In this course, we'll be
building a useful shopping list
mobile app, which you can use by
yourself or with other people
you live with. And of course,
we'll be using our new friend
Firebase to hook up a real time
database to our app. Now, what
do you need to already know to
take this course? Well, you need
to have a basic understanding of
HTML, CSS, and JavaScript.
Exactly how much more on that a
little bit later. Okay, an
important thing about this
course is that it's challenge
based, which means that rather
than leaning back and just
copying the code that I'm
writing, I'm going to be giving
you a bunch of challenges to
solve. Alright, there are two
ways for you to take this course
number one, of course, is to
take it here on YouTube. And for
that, you'll need to set up your
own local environment. But
number two, and my personal
favorite is to do the
interactive version on Scrimba.
And if you haven't tried Scrimba
before, oh, my God, you're in
for a treat, you'll find the
link to the Scrimba version in
the description below. Okay,
finally, if you enjoy this
course, and you happen to scroll
back to this part of the video,
then I would absolutely love it.
If you could give this video a
like. And if you have any
feedback for me, then please
leave it in the comments below.
Or even better reach out to me
on Twitter, or LinkedIn. And
with all of that said, enjoy the
course. Hey there and welcome to
this new Scrimba course where
we're going to be building a
mobile app using Firebase. Don't
you find it frustrating when you
want to make some dinner and in
the middle of cooking, you find
out that you're out of a key
ingredient. So now you got to
get all dressed up and go to the
grocery store. But wait, what
other things did you need to get
again? Yeah, well, you see the
problem here, right? Now here's
the thing for 99.9% of people
out there, making their own app
would be an impossible dream,
but not you because you're a
programmer now, which means that
you can use your newly gained
superpowers to solve a problem
in your life by building your
own app. Now, how cool is that?
All right, I hope you're as
excited as I am. Let me show you
what we will be building
introducing Add to Cart a
shopping list app that lets you
keep track of what you need for
your home and makes going to the
grocery store. Easy peasy. You
can even use the app with your
partner family or flatmates. We
even have a testimonial here
from a diehard fan. Now let's
see how it works. All right, so
this is the homescreen. And this
is where you put in the name of
the item that you want to get,
let's put in oranges. And then
let's press Add to Cart. Boom,
there it is added Perfect. Now
let's add some more items. There
we go. Very nice. Now when you
go to the grocery store, you can
just open up this app on your
phone and start checking off
items that you've put in your
cart already. Let's delete
oranges by clicking on it
perfect. Now, that's what I'm
talking about. Now, I gotta
mention at this point that what
we'll be building is not
technically a native mobile app.
It's a web app that's disguised
as a mobile app. But by using a
special technique, our app will
look and feel like a native
mobile app. And we'll even be
able to put it on the home
screen of our phones, both iOS
and Android. Now the question
is, what do you need to know in
order to take this course? Well,
you definitely need to have a
good understanding of HTML and
CSS, how good you ask, well, you
need to be able to code this by
yourself. And if you don't know
how to do that yet, don't worry,
I got you covered. You want to
start off with pears free
course, learn HTML and CSS, you
can get to it by clicking here.
Alright, now what about
JavaScript? Now I'm going to
show you a bunch of concepts
related to JavaScript. Now pause
here and read through all of
these carefully. If you feel
comfortable in all or most of
these concepts, then you're
good. And if not, don't panic,
because you can learn all the
JavaScript you need by taking
pairs free JavaScript course on
scramble, click here to access
it, and then you can come back
to this one. Alright, now that
we've got all of that covered,
let me introduce you to the hero
of this course. Ah, damn wrong
picture. Sorry. There we go. In
this course, we're going to be
learning how to set up our own
database using a popular service
by Google called Firebase. So
very quickly, what is Firebase?
Well, Firebase has a database
which means that users can save
data to Firebase, which can be
accessed from anywhere in the
world and you browser any day
vise next Firebase allows the
database to be updated in real
time. Which means that if I make
a change to the database on my
device, it will be immediately
visible for everyone using the
app as well. And finally, and my
personal favorite, Firebase is
very easy to use, which makes it
the perfect database for
beginners. Now, before we start
this course, I feel like we need
to get to know each other a
little bit better. So here's a
little bit about me. My name is
Rafa Nadal, super easy to
pronounce. I know, I was born in
India in 1991. Then I moved to
Norway with my family when I was
five years old. And I've lived
here ever since three idiots is
one of my favorite movies.
Seriously, if you haven't
watched it yet, you got to see
it. I absolutely adore butter
chicken with garlic naan Of
course. And finally, the thing I
love the most in this world,
apart from my wife, of course,
is technology, learning about
it, and especially sharing what
I know with others. So I hope
you're ready to start this
course with me, make sure to
grab your favorite drink, I'll
do the same.
And let's get coding. Okay, so
what's the first step, I've
actually gone ahead and set up
the basic HTML for us to get
started faster. So we have an
input field here with an ID and
a placeholder. And then we have
a button here as well, which you
can see right here. Let's run
that. Yep, that's working. And
then we have just a little bit
of CSS here to just to take care
of the margin and the padding,
let's take a look at the
index.js file. So here, I
already have a challenge for
you. Because I want you to make
it so that whenever you write
something in here and press this
button, whatever you wrote in
here to get console logged. So
take a pause here, try it out
for yourself, and I'll be with
you very soon.
Good luck.
Okay, I
hope that wasn't too bad. Let's
take a look at it together. So
the first thing we want to do,
of course, is to find a way to
connect what we have here the
HTML elements with the
JavaScript. So the way we want
to do that is use const first,
and then make an input field, l,
I'll call it short for element
variable. And in here, we're
going to use our trusty old pal
document, dot get element by ID,
of course. And what was the
thing that we named it here,
let's take a look here, input
field. So we'll say input in put
field right here, perfect. The
other thing, of course, is going
to be the add button L. And
we'll say again, get element by
ID, and that I believe was just
add button like this. Perfect.
And what is it that needs to be
clicked before something
happens? That's the button
right? So let's attach an event
listener to the add button L
that we just created. So let's
do add button L and then add
event listener. Inside of here,
of course, we want to be
listening for the click event.
And what is it that we want to
happen? Well, let's make the
function First, open up that
with curly brackets. And inside
of here, I always just like to
make sure that things are
working by just doing a very
simple it works console log.
Let's try that out. Now. Run and
click, it works perfect. Okay,
what's the next step now? So we
got to get whatever value is
entered in the input field when
the button is pressed, okay, so
I know for sure that I am going
to need this because this is
where all that data is saved,
right? So I'm going to put that
in here. And first just console
log that let's try that first
run and console log, that
console logs the entire HTML,
right? So what is it that we
want from that? Well, we don't
want HTML, of course, we want
the value that is entered. And
so here, we can use dot value,
this method that gets us the
value. So let's try it out. Now.
run this again. And I'm gonna go
in here and say, hot dogs. And
hot dogs console logged Perfect.
Now, before we end this, I do
want to add a little bit more
code here. Because I just think
that it's much better to do it
this way. Let me show you. So in
here, I'm going to make a
variable. And I'm going to say
that it's input value. And I'm
going to set that equal to input
field L dot value. And then I'm
going to use this instead. To
say that I'm going to console
log that instead. There we go.
Oops, get rid of that. There we
are. Now, why is this better?
While it does the same thing,
but this is much better, because
we know that we want to use
input value later to write and
it's much better to have it
defined up here once and then
just use this in the rest of the
code. So good job on working on
the first challenge, and I'll
see you in the next one.
And now
it's time for you to add the CSS
and here you go. This is how it
should look. So first, we got
this really cute image of a cat.
And then comes the text input
field, and then the button. And
of course, you want to write all
of the CSS code inside of the
index dot css file. And as you
can see here, I've added some
comments here that will give you
some information that you need,
like the Google Font, the
background color, and all that.
And I've already gone ahead and
added the Google Fonts code
right here. Now remember, this
is a pretty big challenge. So
give it your best shot. But
don't worry too much if you
don't get it exactly right. So
pause the scrim here, do the
challenge. And I'll be back in
just a few moments. Good luck.
And we're back. I hope that went
well. Let's have a look at it
together. So first thing I want
to do here is inside of the
index dot HTML file, I want to
add a div container so that all
the elements are inside of the
container. There we go. And then
we want to add an image tag, of
course, for the cat, let's do
assets and then cat dot png. Is
that working? Let's have a look.
And we have the cat up here.
Perfect or perfect? Get it? I'm
sorry, for the bad joke. Let's
go over to the CSS file. Okay,
Let's uncomment all of this
first. There we go. Okay,
already looking better. Okay, so
what do we want to start with?
I'm going to actually start with
the container. Let's do
container. And I do want to use
Flexbox here. So I'm going to
say display flex right away.
There we go. And I do want to
set the flex direction to be
column. Perfect. And then let's
do max width 320 pixels. Now,
why am I doing this this max
width? Well, it turns out that
if we set the max width to be
320 pixels, that basically all
devices in the world, especially
mobile devices, will be able to
show that no problem. Alright,
so what's next, let's center
this container. So I'm going to
use margin for that. Let's do
margin 20 pixels, auto, maybe,
maybe let's put a little bit
more there. 30 pixels. Okay,
looking better. Now, let's fix
up this image first. So let's go
in here and target the image.
And then we're going to do with
150 pixels, much better. And
then of course, again, use
margin here to center that as
well. Perfect. Now let's take
care of the input field and the
button. And as you can see here,
they both look very similar. So
we can do some copy pasting
here. So let me start with the
text input field first. Okay,
let's get rid of the border
first, zero, perfect. And then
let's add some padding 15
pixels, perhaps. Okay, that's
looking pretty good. Now, we do
want a border radius as well.
And what do we want to do here
five, maybe that's a little bit
too little, and maybe do eight
instead. Okay, looking better.
Now we do want to increase the
font size to so let's do font
size. I'm going to do 20 pixels.
All right, that's looking pretty
good. Now. Now what else is
there, we do want to center the
text. So let's do text align
center. And then of course, we
want to apply the Google Font
turns out, you have to manually
do it for the text input field
and the button, it's not good
enough to put it here. a bummer.
But that's how it is. Let's copy
that and put that in right
there. Awesome. Okay, I think
it's looking pretty good. So I'm
going to actually go ahead and
copy all of this, and paste that
in right here. And of course,
now it looks pretty much
identical to this. Now I'm going
to get rid of these two. And
there we go. See, that's all
what was needed. Now, we do want
to add some spacing here between
these two elements. And perhaps
this element too. So why don't
we pick the middle element,
which is the input field, of
course, and add a little bit of
margin, top and bottom. So let's
do 10 pixels. Yeah, that's
looking pretty good. Now, let's
make it a little bit smaller
here and compare it. Is it
looking good? Yes, it's looking
pretty much identical. So
awesome job. Now we're done with
most of the CSS and we can focus
on the JavaScript. I'll see in
the next scrim. All righty, in
this scrim, we're going to be
setting up our very first
Firebase real time database. I
don't know about you. But I am
super excited about this.
Because this is where we take
our projects to the next level,
a database is going to give us
the ability to save data that
can be accessed by anyone in the
world. So the first step, of
course, is to head over to the
Firebase console. Click this
link to open it up on your side.
Once you're there, make sure
that you sign in using your
Google account. If you don't
have one, you have to create
one. Okay, once you're logged
in, you'll see this press Create
a project then you can name the
project playground, check off
these two things and press
Continue. We don't need Google
Analytics for this project. So
just disable it and press Create
Project, it's going to take a
couple of seconds, and it's
going to set up the project for
you. Once it's done, press
Continue, it's going to take you
to your console. Now, on the
left side, you'll see real time
database, click on that, then
press on create database, it's
going to ask you which location
Do you want to go for, pick the
one that is closest to you, I'm
going to go for Belgium, then
it's going to ask you do you
want to set the database in
locked mode or test mode, we're
going to go for test mode now.
So choose that and press enable.
And there we go, we have our
real time database setup. Now
the final step is to go over
here and press on this icon to
copy the database reference URL,
which we're going to use in just
a little bit. All right, so let
me show you the app that I have
here. This is called real time.
And it's just a simple movie app
where you can add the movies
that you want to watch with
someone together pretty stupid,
I know. But it'll illustrate the
point. So the first thing I'm
going to do is go all the way up
here and make a const and say,
app settings, I'm going to set
this equal to be an object. And
in there, I'm going to say
database URL. And that I'm going
to set to the string that I just
copied from Firebase, remember
your database reference URL,
paste that in here, let's
minimize the browser. There we
are perfect. Now going forward,
you have to make sure that
whenever I give you challenges,
or you're running the code on
your end, you need to make sure
that this is replaced with your
specific database URL,
otherwise, you'll be writing to
my database. And that's not a
good thing. Because imagine
1000s and 1000s of students
writing to the same little
database, that's going to be
pretty chaotic. So just remember
that going forward. Okay, so
what's next? Now in order to use
Firebase, we need to use some
code that lives on Firebase
servers. So how do we do that?
Exactly. So let's look at a very
simple example that I have set
up and then come back to this.
So on the left side, you'll
notice that I made a file called
functions.js. Let's go inside of
there. This has a very simple
function that just adds two
numbers together. But you'll
notice that it has a keyword in
front export. What does that
mean? Well, imagine that I want
to use this function, not on
this file, but in a different
JavaScript file. How would I do
that? Well, the first step would
be to write the function here,
and then add export, so it can
be exported to another file. And
then you got to go into the file
that you want to actually use it
in and use the Import keyword
first import, and then whatever
we want to import, we have to
put inside of curly brackets
like this. So what is it that we
want to import? Well, we want to
use the add function. So we'll
just say add, just this right
here. Okay, what next? Now we
have to tell it, where do you
get it from? So that's going to
be this file, right? So we have
to say import this thing from?
And then we'll say functions.js.
So can we start using add here?
We actually can, and I want you
to make sure that it can. So the
challenge is console log add, by
using just two numbers, pause
here, and I'll see you in a bit.
All right, I hope that went
well. You probably had some
trouble with it, I can't
imagine. Let me show you what I
mean. Let's go in here. Now, of
course, you would think okay,
let's just do console log. And
let's just do ad and then one
and one, right, so this should
work. But that actually gives us
an error, it says cannot use
import statement outside of
module. So in addition to this,
we actually got to go inside of
the index dot HTML. And here, we
have to say type, and then
module. This is the only way
this will work. Now, there's one
more thing we forgot, we
actually also have to use the
functions or js file here. So we
got to say functions.js. And
both of them need to be set to
module because you need module
to be able to export it, and
then import it. So both of them
need to be set to module. Let's
try it out now. Run that. And
now it worked. Perfect. All
right back to Firebase. I'm
going to get rid of this. And
we're actually going to be
importing a Firebase function
called initialize app. And where
are we going to get it from?
We're going to be getting it
from this location. There we go.
And if you want to see what this
code contains, just feel free to
copy this and open it up in a
new tab. You'll see all of the
code there. And we specifically
want the function that is
initialize app from this
location. All right, so with
that set up, let's go here and
make a const and call it app.
And for that, we're going to use
the Initialize function that we
just imported. And what are we
going to give it as an argument,
we'll see the app settings here
which has the specific database
URL, this is going to be the
missing link, because this
information here is going to
connect our project with the
project that contains this
database. So let's do that. Now.
Let's go in here. and see app
settings. There we go. And we do
want to see if this is working.
So let's just do a console log.
And we'll just console log app,
see what we get. I don't know
what we're gonna get. And we get
this. Let's have a closer look,
open up the console. What do we
see here? Okay, Firebase app.
Alright, that's good. And we get
the database URL. And that's the
one that we're using. Perfect.
There seems to be communication
now between the Firebase
database and our specific
project. Alright, so what's
next, let's get rid of the
console and keep going. So next,
I'm going to make another const
here and call it database. And
actually, for this, we have to
import another Firebase
function. And so this time, I
want you to import that. So time
for another challenge, import
the get database, Firebase
function from this place right
here, following the same
principle as up here, pause
here, try it out for yourself.
I'll be with you soon. Good
luck. Alright, I hope that went
well. I'm going to just copy
this URL, get rid of this. And
then say, import, get database
from this place right here. And
you'll notice here, the only
difference between these two is
the app and the database.
Alright, with that important,
let's go back here and say, Get
database. Now, again, we got to
feed it some information, right,
that's the only way this is
going to work. So let's feed it
the app object inside of here.
There we go. Now we're getting
pretty close to this being
finished, there's just one
little thing that we're missing.
So let's have a closer look at
our database. So this is where
we can start pushing data. But
before we can do that, we need
to create something called a
reference. Now, what is a
reference? Well, a reference in
this case is any location inside
of the database. And so since it
doesn't have any data yet, we're
going to create a reference here
called movies, where all of the
movies that be pushed using this
input field, and pressing this
button are going to go inside of
that reference. If that was a
little bit too technical for
you. Don't worry it, let's just
make it work. And we're going to
be hearing the word referenced
several times during the
section. Okay, so let's make
another variable here. And I
want to call this movies in dB
short for database, of course.
And let's open that up. And
again, we need to use another
function, import it from this
place right here. So let's go up
here, say comma, and then ref.
Short for reference. Let's go in
here and say, ref. Now ref takes
in two different things. First,
which database are you working
with? You got to see that
explicitly. So let's say
database, because we got that up
here. Right? So it knows what
that means. Now, the second
argument is going to be what the
reference should be called.
Let's just call that movies. All
right. So is it going to work?
Let's see, if we enter anything
here and press this do you think
anything's going to happen? So I
already went ahead and added
this code, right? The input
value, and then it console logs,
whatever you put in, and it says
added to database. But there's
no code here that we've added
that specifically pushes this to
the database, we're going to do
that. And for that, of course,
you probably guessed it, we need
another function from Firebase.
So let's go up here and say,
push. Now watch this. Let's go
in here and say, push. And what
do we want to push? We want to
push the input value. But is
that enough? No, because we need
to tell this function exactly
where we want to push this in
the database. So we want to give
it the reference first. So let's
do movies in dB for that. And
now let's cross our fingers and
try it out. Let's run this. And
of course, get rid of this
annoying thing first. Now, I'm
going to enter in a movie here,
let's say three idiots, press.
Did that work? Yes, it did.
Let's have a look. And it added
it to the database. Again, if it
didn't work for you make sure
that you changed this URL to
your database URL. So I'm going
to add Shawshank Redemption. And
I'm going to add another movie
to School of Rock. And did those
two get added? Indeed they did.
And we got all three of them
their amazing work, we finally
have our Firebase real time
database hooked up to our
project. Great job. And I'll see
you in the next one. Now. It is
finally time for us to set up
Firebase for our project. Let's
get into it right away. So I
want to start you off with a big
challenge. And here it is. Make
sure to read this very carefully
before you get started. And
again, this is a big one. So
please don't stress too much if
you don't quite get it. And
please feel free to go back and
refresh your memory if you need
to. So with that, pause here and
give it a go. I wish you all the
best and I'll see you in a few
moments.
Okay, how did
it go? If you manage to do all
of that 10 Bravo, let's have a
look at it together. So first
thing we got to do, of course,
is head over to the Firebase
console, then press Create a
project, name it real time
database, check off these two
things continue, disable Google
Analytics continue, project
completed, continue. Now on the
left side, let's go to real time
database, create database,
choose your nearest location,
choose Test mode, and then
enable. And here we go. We have
our database setup, make sure to
copy the database reference URL.
Okay, let's dive into the code.
So let's head on over to
index.js. And I'm actually going
to give you a challenge again.
So I want you to first import
the Firebase function initialize
app from this place, and then
get database from this one. So
pause here, give it a go. And
I'll be right back.
All right,
I hope that went well. I'm
actually going to use these
comments to do this. See import
there. And we want to make sure
that these are inside of curly
brackets. And there we go.
That's it. Same thing. Here
import.
Perfect.
Okay, now you can relax a little
bit, because I've given you two
challenges back to back. Let me
take over for a bit. Okay, let's
go back to the Firebase console
and make sure to copy the
database reference URL. Once we
have that, let's go back here
and say const. And then app
settings, make that an object
and say database URL, and set
that equal to this database
reference URL. Now, again, I
have to reiterate that whenever
you're interacting with scrims
in this section, you got to make
sure to use your own database
URL. Otherwise, as you can
imagine, there's going to be
chaos inside of this app. All
right, so what's next, let's set
up an app variable and set that
equal to initialize app. And we
need to give it some
information, we need to give it
an argument, that's going to be
the app settings that we've set
up, right, which contains the
database URL, which is going to
be the key thing that's going to
connect our project with
Firebase. Alright, so what's
next, then we're going to set up
a database variable. That of
course, uses get database. And
in here, we're going to pass in
the app. Alright, one last thing
remaining here. And that's going
to be setting up the reference.
So what should we call this
thing? Let's call it shopping
list in dB, and set that equal
to ref. Now, of course, we got
to remember to import that from
up here. So ref. And of course,
the ref functions takes in two
things, first, the database. And
then we got to call this
reference something. Let's call
it shopping list. Okay, let's
pause here for a little bit to
see if this is even working.
Let's press run. And we get an
error cannot use import
statement, our we forgot to do
that key thing. Let's go into
index dot HTML. And we always
have to remember to go in here
and say type module. When do we
need to do this? Anytime inside
of any JavaScript file where
we're either using the Import or
the export, or both of them, we
have to set this equal to
module, otherwise, it's not
going to work. All right, let's
test it out again. All right, we
didn't get an error. So
hopefully that's working. Now to
conclude this scrim, I want to
actually give you a final
challenge that we put it right
here. So I want you to use the
Firebase function push to push
the input value to the database.
So pause here, try it out for
yourself, and I'll be right
back. Okay, I hope that went
well. Let's do it together.
Let's do push. And first, we got
to give it the reference, which
in our case is going to be
shopping list in dB. And then
we're going to just give it
input value. Now, is this going
to work? Well, not exactly
because we haven't imported push
from up here yet. Alright, let's
test it out now. So I'm going to
press Run, open this up. I'm
going to put in oranges here.
Let's cross our fingers and
press this button. And I see
that it worked for me. Great. I
hope you got it to work on your
side as well. Awesome job. And
I'll see you in the next scrim.
Just a very quick scrim where
I'm going to cover something
that I glossed over in the
previous two scrims, and that's
security rules. Now if you
remember when we created our
real time database, we chose to
start in test mode. Now this is
a perfectly fine way to start.
However, as you can see, this
message right here says
something important. The default
security rules for test mode,
allow anyone with your database
reference to view, edit and
delete all data in your database
for the next 30 days. Now what
that means is is that reading
and writing to the database can
be done by anyone starting when
you created the database and
until the next 30 days, which
means whatever the time is, at
this moment in time denoted by
now here It must be less than
this long and weird number. Now
this is just one way to
represent time in programming.
It's called Unix epoch time. And
if you'd like to play around
with it, you can just go to
epoch converter.com, or click
here. But Firebase has been
helpful here and giving us this
as a comment, which you can see
is the 10th of February 2023.
While is definitely past that
date now, which means that we
won't be able to read or write
anything to the database. Let's
fix that. So let's go back to
our database. And as you can see
up here, you'll see rules in the
menu. Let's click on that, there
we go. So as you can see here,
there are two rules, one for
read and one for right now just
click anywhere here to edit the
text. Now you want to go ahead
and change both of them to true,
remember the comma in between.
So this means that anyone can
read and write to the database.
Now, is this a perfect scenario?
Absolutely not. Because it means
that literally anyone can write
to your database. However, if
you're only using this app by
yourself or just with a couple
of other people in your life,
then it doesn't need to be a
problem, because you'll only be
sharing your app URL with those
people. So let's go ahead and
publish the changes. Now you'll
see this warning message which
says exactly what I just
explained. But for my database,
I'm going to actually set the
writing rule to false because I
want to make sure that my
database doesn't get spammed,
you know what I mean, which is
also why whenever you run the
code on Scrum, but during this
project, you will not be able to
write anything to my app. So
that said for this scrim, this
is actually a very important
aspect of Firebase. And
something we'll definitely cover
in much greater depth in a
future Firebase course with that
covered on to the next one.
Alright, so before we can work
on fetching the database items
from Firebase, we need to first
write the code that will
actually add the item to the
DOM. In other words, we need to
write the JavaScript that's
going to add the HTML necessary
to show the items right down
here. So at this point, you've
actually already done this
before, you've been using
innerHTML to add HTML stuff
using JavaScript. So I'm going
to give you this task as a
challenge. But before that,
let's quickly add the necessary
HTML code we need. There we go.
So we got our UL right here with
ID shopping list. And to Li is
that I have as examples here,
oranges and hotdogs, which let's
be honest, here are really the
only things you need to survive,
right? Let's see if that works
or not run. And we got those
perfect. Okay, let's go over to
the JavaScript file. So I have
the challenge written out right
here. So you basically want to
make it so that whatever you put
in here, and you press the
button, that gets appended right
at the end here. So pause here
and give it a go yourself, and
I'll be with you in a few
seconds. And we'll look at it
together. Now, before you start.
If you don't remember how to do
this, feel free to go back a
little bit and refresh your
memory. Okay,
good luck. Okay,
did you get it? Well, let's look
at it together. So the first
thing I think about here is we
need to connect our HTML and our
JavaScript. And I'm going to do
that right up here. So let's do
const. And make a shopping list
element. And of course, we're
going to use our favorite method
here, get element by ID, and we
call it shopping list. There we
go. Once that is done, I can
just copy this, put it right in
here. And what do we want to
apply to this thing? Well, we
definitely want to use inner
HTML. And then of course, we
want to say plus equals, and
this is where I'm going to be
using template strings, because
that's going to let us do this
in a very elegant way. So let's
do backticks. And inside here,
first, let's open it up with an
LI tag. And then we're going to
say, input value. Close that
with a curly bracket and then
enter that thing. There we go.
Does that work? Let's test it
out. Open that thing up. And
let's try adding some chocolate
here. Chocolate, add to cart and
it added it right there.
Amazing. Did it add it to the
database? Yep, it did that too.
Perfect. Now before we end this
scrim, I've noticed something
that I really want to fix. It's
a super simple thing. But did
you notice that? Do you notice
that when you enter in something
here and press the button, it
doesn't clear the input field.
And that's really annoying,
because we want to make this
thing as user friendly as
possible. In fact, why don't you
go ahead and add that code?
Pause here, give it a go. And
I'll be right back. Okay, I hope
that went well. So what are we
doing here? So we definitely
want to start using the input
field element. Let's copy that
here. Now what is it that we
want to do to it? Well, the
value is this thing right here,
right? And that's what we want
to reset. And how can we do
that? Let's just say that the
value should would be equal to
the empty string. That should
work. Let's try it out, run. And
I'll add a Red Bull here and
press this. And there we go, it
clears it. Now notice that the
chocolate disappeared. And
that's because we haven't
started fetching the database
items from our actual database.
But don't worry, we're going to
do that pretty soon. Great job
so far. And let's keep going.
Okay, I feel
like we got to take a little
pause here, because you have
been doing an incredible job.
Seriously, just think about when
you started off learning with
Scrimba. You were learning
simple HTML and CSS not too long
ago. And now you're making your
own mobile app, and you've just
hooked up an actual database to
your project. Isn't that crazy?
Now, just think about how good
you can get if you continue
coding, how amazing Are you
going to be in three months, six
months, a year, five years?
Truly amazing to think about if
you asked me. So with that,
let's have a look at the
challenges for the scrim. So in
this one, we're going to be
spending some time refactoring
our code. It's always good to
pause every now and then to
rewrite your code. In a better
way, this gets more and more
important, the more complex your
projects get. And it's
especially important when you
work with other developers. So
here are the two challenges that
I have for you. So take this
line of code and refactor it,
which means just create a new
function for it. And the same
thing with this one. So take a
pause here, try it out for
yourself, and I'll be with you
in just a little bit. Good luck.
All right, I hope that went
well. So how do we think about
this? Well, I definitely want to
take the first line of code and
cut it from here. So let's cut
it from here. And let's remove
this as well. And then we're
going to go down here, I'm going
to make a new function. Now what
do we want to call this
function? I don't know. Let me
just give it a temporary name.
Let's just call it Hello. And
then we're going to paste in
that line of code. And now let's
think about a good name for this
function. So what is this
function doing? Well, it's
taking the input field element,
and it's setting the value to be
the empty string. So it's kind
of clearing the input field,
right? It's resetting it. So I
like the word clear more. So why
don't we call this clear? input
field? L? So clear. Make sense,
right? And what is it clearing
the input field L, which is
exactly what this is called as
well. So that kind of makes
sense, right? So once we've done
this, we can actually take this
function and copy it and call it
up here. So it actually runs. So
that's the first one. What about
the second one. So let's start
off the same way. We want to cut
it from here, cut that, and then
let's remove this. And we want
to make a function down here.
Again, I'm not really sure what
I should call it. So I'm just
going to call it hello for now.
And then in here, let's paste in
the function. There we go. Oops,
there we are. Now let's think
about what this function is
doing. So this one takes the
shopping list element uses the
inner HTML to append the input
value at the very bottom. Okay.
Hmm. Okay, so what element is it
that it's changing? It's
changing the shopping list out?
All right, so it's appending, a
new item to the shopping list L.
Let's just write that out. So
I'm going to go with a pend item
to, and I'm just going to copy
this and paste it in there. And
of course, we're using camel
case here. So I want to turn
this into a capital S. Let's see
how that sounds. Append item to
shopping list L. Is that a super
long function name, kind of? Is
that a problem? No, I don't
really see a problem with this.
It's a pretty good function
name. If you ask me. Let's go
with it. Now, is this going to
work? Let's copy this up here.
And then try to run it. Let's
run that. Let's see read. Does
that work? It's not working,
because it's giving us input
value is not defined. Of course.
What do we have here? We have
the input value. Does that mean
anything inside of this
function? No, this is coming
from up here, right? That's the
one. So we got to use a
parameter in this case. So why
don't we go in here and say that
we're going to feed it the input
value, whatever that happens to
be. And then in here, we're
going to create a parameter and
let's just call it item of
value. And I'm going to take
that one instead. And use that
in here. All right, so let's try
that again. Now. Let's do bread
once more. Is that going to
work? There we go. Now it works
perfect. Now next up, we're
going to be looking at how to
fetch items from the database
and do that in Real Time.
However, before we can do that,
we need to go on a tiny little
tangent here, so that we can
learn about something that we
really need to know. And that is
how to take a JavaScript object
and transform it into an array.
Okay, see you in the next one.
So much of coding is about
turning a piece of data in a
specific format to another
format. As programmers, we need
to do that all the time. So
let's have a look at what kind
of data we have here. So here we
have a let variable called
scramble users, that is an
object that contains three
users. The key is the ID of the
user. And then the value is the
email address. Now what if we
wanted to turn this object into
an array? Now, you might be
asking yourself, why would we
even want to do that in the
first place? Well think about
it, maybe you want to write a
for loop, and you prefer to work
with a race. Okay, so how do you
do that? Exactly? Well, in this
case, it turns out that the
awesome people that contribute
to the JavaScript language,
already thought about this. In
JavaScript, we have an object
type, and you can get to it by
writing object with a capital O.
Now, we don't need to worry too
much about what types are
exactly at this point, what we
are interested in right now is
how to use a method on object.
So we can convert this object
into an array. Alright, let me
show you. So what we want to do
here is say object and then dot,
and then I'm going to write
values. Okay, and this is a
method, of course, so we got to
end it with these parentheses.
And we can also feed in the
object that we want to use here.
So I'm going to take this, copy
it and put it right here. Now,
of course, we do want to console
log this. So let's do console
log, right here. And let's see
what we can run. And we get an
array. Let's have a closer look.
Yes, it is indeed an array, and
we get all the email addresses.
This is perfect. Now, what if
you wanted the keys instead?
What if you didn't want the
values but the keys? Well, of
course, we have that too. So for
that, we just change values into
keys. Let's run that again. And
there you go, you got the keys.
And then of course, naturally,
you're probably thinking, Okay,
what if I wanted both, while
they thought about this, as
well, of course. And so the
final method I'm going to give
you is going to be entries, and
this is going to give you a
little bit more complex of an
array. Let's have a look. And
see, it gives you an array that
contains arrays that each have
two different things in it
first, the key and then the
value. So in this case, we get
both. Alright, now before we end
the scrim, I want to give you
three challenges to get some
practice with this. So I'm going
to remove this. And here are the
challenges. Make sure to read
them carefully. Pause here, try
it out for yourself. And I'll be
right back. Good luck. Alright,
I hope that went well. Let's
have a look at it together. So
first, I'm going to go for let's
and then scramble users emails,
set that equal to object. And
then of course, the first one
that we learned was the values
one, right? And what is it take?
Well, it's going to have to take
this one, that's the only thing
we have. That's the object. So
this together now is going to
return us an array. Let's see if
that's actually the case by
console logging it here. console
log, this one, let's see added
gives us the emails Perfect. Now
once I've done this, the rest
are pretty easy. So I'm going to
just copy this one, put it right
down here. Replace it now with
IDs instead. IDs. And what do we
want in this case, we don't want
the values we want the keys. So
let's see if that works now.
Beautiful. Okay, the last one,
again, copy this one, put it
down here. And then we go for
entries instead this time. And
of course, we want to use
entries like that. Let's see if
that gives us the final one. And
there we go. Perfect. As I said
earlier on, this is a very
useful thing. Programmers change
the format of the data all the
time. All right, great job with
this one.
In this grim,
we're going to be using a
magical Firebase function that
will make it super easy for us
to get exactly what we need from
the database whenever it changes
in any way. I hope you're ready
for it. Okay, so let's spend a
little bit of time looking at
exactly what's going to be
happening here. So this thing
right here is a real time
database. You'll see this type
of icon pretty often. It's
usually used to denote a
database. And so here we have a
person using our app on their
phone. This app uses this
database to store all of its
data. Now this party right here
is also called the client, if
you've ever heard that technical
word before. Now, of course, the
client could be using any device
could be an iPad, other kind of
tablet, desktop, computer,
laptop, Android phone doesn't
really matter. So let's bring in
another client right over here.
Now this person is also using
the same app, which of course
also uses the same database. And
so let's say that this client
over here adds in some value to
the input field, and presses
this button, at which point the
data is saved on to the
database. Now, we've already
done this, but this is where the
magic happens. Because right
after this action has taken
place, the database immediately
sends a signal to everywhere
saying that the database has
been updated. In fact, it does
something even better, it
actually sends the new data from
the database to all of its
clients. Now, this data at this
moment in time is something that
Firebase refers to as a
snapshot. We'll be working a lot
with snapshots in this scrim, so
just get used to that word.
Okay, now let's have a look at
the app that I've got set up
here. So this app is called a
best REITs. And it's supposed to
show your favorite books right
under here. Now, I've already
gone ahead and written the HTML,
CSS, and most of the JavaScript
for it already. Now, before we
start adding any code here, I
want to show you how you can add
data to the database through the
Firebase console. So if you
don't already have it open, let
me show you a shortcut on how to
do that, you can just copy this
URL for the database, of course,
use the one that you're using,
and just open that up in a new
tab, it's going to take you to
your Firebase Console to the
real time database. All right,
so I've got my real time
database right up here. The
first thing we want to do is go
right up here, and then press
this plus button. Once you've
done that, this is going to
appear, it's going to ask you
for a key and a value. Go ahead
and write books right in here.
There we go. Now, instead of
putting something in for the
value, we're going to just go
ahead and press this plus
button. And did you see what
just happened there, this now
allows us to nest the data
inside of the books, which is
exactly what we want. Okay, so
let's go ahead and add our first
book. For the key, we're going
to say one, and for the book,
I'm going to put in make time,
which is one of my favorite
books. Once you're done with
that, go ahead and press Add,
boom, we got make time in there
perfect. Now let's go ahead and
add another book, go up here and
press the plus button again. And
then again, we want to put in
two here. And then I'm going to
put an animal farm one of my all
time favorite novels, go ahead
and press add. And there we go.
We got two items. I think that's
good enough. Okay, now let's go
back to the code. So what's the
first thing that we want to do?
Well, in order for us to fetch
the database items in that
magical way that I was talking
about, we want to use the on
value function. So let's go up
here and import it. First, we're
going to see on value Perfect.
Now what now let's go down here
and start using this function.
So how do we use it exactly,
first, go ahead and just write
on value. And then let's open up
the parentheses. Now the first
argument that we want to give it
is going to be the reference
where we want to fetch the data
from now what is that? Well,
that's going to be this one
right here, the books one, and
I've already got that set up
here. It's using the reference
function right here. So I'm
gonna go ahead and copy this and
put that in right there. Okay,
now we know where we want to get
the data from. Now, what's next,
the next argument is going to be
a function, which inside
actually contains the snapshot,
so we're going to be able to use
the snapshot inside of here.
Okay, let's go ahead and open
that up. Okay. So as always, we
want to just do a test first. So
let's go ahead and console log
snapshot just to make sure that
things are working. All right,
let's go ahead and press Run and
hope for the best. And there we
go. We got both of them.
Perfect. Now let's open up the
console. And you'll notice here
that this is an object and we
don't really want to work with
objects. In this case, we want
to turn this into an array. So
let's go ahead and do that.
Okay, so let's make some space
up here. And let's make a left
variable and call it books
array. Now, how do we turn an
object into an array? Well, we
just learned how to do that,
right? So let's do object and
then values. And then inside is
where we want to put the
snapshot. Okay, hopefully, this
is going to work. So let's now
console log the books array
instead, press run again. And we
get something very weird that I
do not understand. It does look
like an array, but it's not
quite right. problem here is
that we don't want to use
snapshot directly, we want to
actually say snapshot, dot Val,
which is going to make it work
now hopefully let's try it
again. Run. And there we go. Now
we got that beautiful array with
both of our items in it.
Perfect. Okay, now this is where
I want to give you some work to
do. So here's your challenge by
using this array that we just
made. Write a for loop where you
console log each book. Alright,
pause here. Give it a go by
yourself, and I'll be right
back. Good luck
Okay, I hope that went well.
Let's Do it together. Now let's
do for let i equals zero. And
then I smaller than books array,
of course, the length of that.
And then we want to do i plus
plus super standard stuff. Let's
open that up. And we want to do
console log. And then we want to
do this books array, but not the
whole array. We want the item of
it right. And so we can console
log that. Okay, so let's see if
this works. Now, Ron, do we get
it? Yes, we get both of them
perfect. Now, before we end
this, I do want to add something
here because I normally like to
do it this way, let's say
current book, and then put this
right up there first. Once we
have that, we can just use
current book in here, pores,
let's make sure that that also
works. Of course, that's going
to give us the exact same thing.
Perfect. All right, but we're
not done yet. Because we don't
want to console log the books,
we want to actually show them
here. And I've actually gone
ahead and already made a
function right down here called
append book to books list L.
It's kind of a long one, but use
this function inside of the loop
so that you can show the books
right here. Alright, so I'm
going to put the challenge right
here. So pause here, try it out
for yourself. And I'll be right
back.
All right. I hope that went
well.
Let's have a look at it together
now. So first thing I'm going to
do is just copy this whole
thing, because that's what we
want to use. Put it right down
here. So what is this book value
here? Well, that's the parameter
of the function. And we don't
really have that inside of here.
So we got a substituted with
something. Where's that book?
Well, the book is right up here,
current book. So let's just copy
this and put that in there. And
I believe that's all we got to
do. So let's see if that works.
Let's run that. And do we get
it? Indeed we do. We get both of
these here. Let's make it a
little bit bigger. And there we
go. Perfect. Now at this point,
you might be thinking are great,
we're done. Not so fast. Because
let me show you what can happen.
So let's say that you go into
the database, and you make a
change. Let's say that we want
to change the title of this for
make time to make time. And I
don't know why you would want to
do that. But let's just do it to
demonstrate a point here. So
let's go inside of the database.
And what you can do is you can
just go ahead and press this,
and it's going to let you edit
it. So I'm going to do that on
my side A B, go ahead and change
that. Now before I press enter
to make this happen. Let's see
what happens here now. Okay, I'm
going to press enter in 321. Did
you see let's have a look what
just happened, it didn't remove
the first books, it appended it
at the end, this is a problem,
because every time the database
is going to be updated, it's not
going to clear any of the first
stuff, it's just going to keep
adding that's going to be super
chaotic. And we definitely don't
want that. So at this point, I
want to give you the last
challenge of this scrim, which
is to try to fix this bug. Now
before you go ahead, though,
notice that there is a function
that we haven't talked about.
And that's the clear books list
L which actually contains the
functionality that you need. Now
you just need to place it
somewhere inside of this on
value function. I don't know
where that's what you're
supposed to figure out. So pause
here, give it a go for yourself.
And I'll be with you in just a
couple of seconds. Good luck.
Okay, so how do we think about
this now? Well, here's how I
think about it. So the on value
function is that special
function that runs every time
there is an edit to the
database. So in this case, we
just changed the title of this
slightly. And so it ran the
entire code. Now this is the
part of the code the for loop
that is actually doing the
appending. But before that we're
not clearing anything. So why
don't we just plain and simple
copy this. And right before the
loop runs, we say Hey, make sure
if there's anything there just
clear it before you start a
pending. Okay, let's see if this
works or not. I'm going to run
this again. Now. Okay. Again, we
have both of the books ah, hold
up right there for just a
second. This is future mean
talking to you. After recording
the scrim I noticed that at this
point, I'm actually seeing both
books on my side. But you're
actually seeing a blank web page
right now with just the best
reads heading. Now this is due
to a little bug with the
scrambled mini browser. But I
want to assure you that this is
actually working. In fact, to
prove it to yourself, you can
pause right here and put in your
database URL right in here, and
then press run. And you will see
that it works. Feel free to make
edits to the database. And it's
going to update here again.
Sorry about this. We're of
course going to try to fix this
as soon as we can. But until
that I hope you can forgive this
bug. So yes, indeed. This code
right here is what fix that bug
that we run into. Now before we
end this really long scrim. I
want to give you an extra well
done. We managed to cover a lot
of ground in this one. All
righty, so it's fine The time
for us to fetch the items from
the database in real time.
Firebase is a gift to the world
seriously. So why don't we just
start the scrim off with a
challenge. So let's go down
here. And I'm going to give you
a challenge right here. So I
want you to call the on value
function, you're going to have
to import it up here first, with
shopping list in dB as the first
argument. And then the function
snapshot as the second argument,
this will get us started
building our own value function.
So pause here, give it a go
yourself, and I'll be right
back. Good luck.
Okay, I
hope that went well. Let's do it
together. So let's do on value.
And then open it up and do
shopping list in dB. First, we
have to specify the reference
first, so it knows exactly where
to fetch the items from. And
then let's make that function.
And then of course, we got this
snapshot in here. And then open
this up. There we are. All
right, it's time for the next
challenge. Here it is console,
log snapshot dot Val to show all
of the items inside of the
shopping list in the database.
Pause here. I'll be right back.
Good luck.
Okay,
so let's see, let's scroll down
a little bit. And let's start
doing this. So let's do console
log, and snapshot dot Val. Let's
see if that works. Run that. And
we have on value is not defined,
obviously, because I forgot the
most basic thing, which happens
all the time. So I'm going to go
up here and import that.
Hopefully you remember to do
that. There we go. Let's run it
again. And we got our object
with all of our items. Perfect.
Okay, now I want to give you the
final challenge for this scrim.
Let me get rid of this first.
And here it is. Use object dot
values to convert snapshot dot
Mal from an object to an array.
And you want to create a
variable for this. And also make
sure to console log the result
just to make sure that it's
actually an array. Good luck,
pause here. I'll be right back.
Okay, let's do this thing. Let's
go up here. And we'll say let an
items array. And we'll set that
equal to object. And of course,
we want to use that object dot
values, right, that gives us
exactly what we need, in this
case, snapshot, dot Val goes in
there. And we do want to make
sure that we console log that
just to make sure that things
are working. As always, let's
run that and see what we get.
And we got that beautiful array.
Perfect, great job working on
the challenges I'll see in the
next one. Okay, so now we've got
the on value function, giving us
the snapshot every time the
database updates. And then we've
turned that into an array right
here. So of course, the next
natural challenge is for you to
write a for loop using this
items array. So that's the
challenge. Pause right here.
Give it a go. And I'll be right
back. All right, let's do it
together. So let's go with four
and let i equals zero. I smaller
than items array, the length of
that, of course, and then i plus
plus. Let's open that up. And
how do we get the specific item
per iteration. That, of course
is going to be items array, and
then the IFE element inside of
that, right. So let's console
log that. And then we'll test
this thing out. Let's run that.
And there we go. We got a full
list. That's perfect. Okay, my
next challenge for you is this
one, use the Append item to
shopping list element function
that we made before inside of
the loop to append each item to
the shopping list element for
each iteration. So basically,
when you run this, all of the
items should show up here. Okay,
good luck, pause here. And I'll
be with you in just a couple of
seconds. All right, I hope that
went well. So what do we do
here? What's the first thing
that we should do? Well, we
definitely want to use this
function. So I'm going to just
go ahead and copy this. And then
paste it right in here. Now let
me get rid of this console log.
And do we have something inside
of here called item value?
Absolutely not. That's the
parameter for this function. So
we got to substitute that with
items array, and then the eighth
element, of course in there,
right. So let's see if that
works. Now, run that. Did we get
it? Yes, we did. Now there seems
to be a little bit of a problem
here because we're getting
oranges and hotdogs up here.
These were just examples that we
added in the beginning. So let's
remove them now. There we go.
Let's go back here again. Try to
run Once more, and then for some
reason we're getting bread two
times. I wonder why that is. But
the rest of them seem to be
right. Actually scratch that.
That's my bad. I actually was
the one who accidentally added
two breads to the database. So
let's actually delete it from
the database. I'm going to do it
from the console and see if this
fixes itself or not. So let's
see here. I'm going to delete
one of them. Yes. And there we
go. Okay, so it now did it two
times, right. So we got to fix
that. Because here we have
everything. And then we have
everything once again. Now at
least it only has one bread. So
let's actually end this scrim
here. And we'll fix this bug in
the next one. Okay, so in the
last scrim, we discovered that
there was a big bug with our
code, whenever there was a
change to the database,
something isn't working, right.
See, we got all of these here.
So what is going on here? Well,
can you guess what I'm going to
say? Now? While if you guessed
that I'll be giving you a
challenge to fix this bug, then
you're absolutely right. Pause
here, try to figure it out by
yourself. And I'll be right
back. Good luck.
Okay, how did
it go? Well, the most important
thing is that you try to think
about it yourself. Okay, so
let's look at the code together.
So I want to immediately go to
the on value function. And so
this function is running
whenever there is a change to
the database, right? And what
are we doing inside here? We're
using the snapshot to turn it
into an array, so that we can
run a four loop on it, right? So
every time this happens, this
for loop is running, which kind
of explains why it's continuing
to add the items at the end.
We're not clearing the items
before that happens, right? So
we got to do that right up here.
So how can we do that? Well, we
can just say, shopping list, l
innerHTML. equals and then the
empty string. So let's try to
run that now. Okay, looking good
so far, let me try to add a new
item to test this thing out now.
Coffee. And we have a new bug.
Or at least maybe this was there
before as well. But we still
haven't fixed all of it yet. At
least it wasn't rendering all
the items now it was just
duplicating this one last year.
Okay, duplication. What does
that mean? To me that says,
okay, there is somewhere in the
code where we can remove
something that is already
happening? Well, this one we
can't remove, because this is
the key thing that's that we
need to keep. But if you look up
here, you'll see that we're
running the same function with
the input value. So we're doing
it two times now. So let's just
get rid of this. And I think
that's going to solve our
problem. Let's run it once more.
And now let's add in solo, which
is a Norwegian soda that we like
here. And now it works perfect.
Okay, but before we end this
scrim, I am looking at this
piece of code right here, I
actually want to take this out
and refactor it. So I'm going to
copy this. And instead of that,
I'm going to say, clear shopping
list L. And we're going to use
this one here. So let's take
this out of here, make a new
function, clear shopping, list
L. And then of course, we're
going to paste that in right
here. Let's test it out again.
There we go. And let's add
something healthy here. Let's
add in a salad, there, we are
perfect. Always grab the
opportunity to refactor your
code. Well done. I'll see you in
the next one. So up until this
point, Flexbox has been making
our lives so much simpler than
it could be. It's one of the
best things about CSS for sure.
Now, let me introduce you to
another feature of Flexbox. That
is just incredible. Let's have a
look at this website right here.
So I've got some of my all time
favorite YouTube videos showing
right here. There's a total of
12 video thumbnails that are
showing here. But the problem is
that these thumbnails are
continuing along this horizontal
line, as you can see by
scrolling. Now, of course, this
is a horrible user experience.
So let's fix this problem by
using something called flex
wrap. Now, check this out. So
all I got to do is tell Flexbox
pay, take all of the elements
inside of this parent div and
wrap it around the max width of
the parent element. Okay, let's
do it now. So flex wrap, and
then we'll say yes, please, we
do want to wrap it. So let's do
that. And there we go. Isn't
that amazing? Do you see how
beautiful that looks? Imagine
how much more CSS we would need
to write without flex wrap. Now
before we end the scrim let me
show you two more values that
you can put right in here. So
the others would be no wrap,
which takes you back to the
default. And then there's wrap
reverse, which of course
reverses the order. So let's
take it back to rap. And there
we go. Beautiful. So here we
have one of the most iconic
album art so One of the best
bands in history written in HTML
and CSS, of course, now
currently, we're using margin
right here in order to create
some spacing between the
pictures of the Beatles. This
right here. Now that's fine, of
course. But now we know Flexbox,
which means that there is a much
cleaner way to achieve the same
result. So instead of using the
individual elements here to
create a margin, we can instead
say to the parent element that
you should create a gap of,
let's say, 10 pixels between all
the child elements. Let me show
you. So let's remove this. There
we go. And let's go in here and
say, gap. And then how much gap
do we want? Let's do 10 pixels.
And there you go. That's all
there is. Now let's add some
more gap. So let's do 20 pixels.
Now, of course, that's too much,
because we have a max width here
of 420. We can increase that to
440, let's say and then we're
back here. Perfect. Now what if
you wanted to have a different
gap top bottom, then left and
right? Well, you can do that in
an easy way here, too. So let's
say go in here. And let's do 10
pixels here. So here, you'll see
left, right is 10 pixels, and
top bottom is 20 pixels. So you
can control even that, but I'm
going to just let it be at 10
pixels. So let's get back to
that.
Okay,
this is where we're going to
take a little pause from working
on JavaScript for just a little
bit so that we can add some more
CSS. As you can see, the list
items are being displayed like
this, which is the default way,
but we want them to be
displaying like this. And so
that's your challenge to solve.
Now, before I let you work on
this, I gotta mention here that
you want to put all of your code
inside of the CSS file. In fact,
I've already gone ahead and
added all of this for you. So
make sure that you write your
code in between here and here.
And there's also a CSS comment
here that includes the
background color, the cream
color that you can see here, and
also the code for the box
shadows right here. Okay, so
this is a big challenge. So
please take your time with this.
And of course, if you don't
fully get it, then that's
completely fine. The most
important thing is that you try.
So pause here and give it a go
by yourself. And I'll be with
you in just a little bit. Good
luck.
Okay, I
hope that went well. Let's have
a look at it together. So what's
the first thing that we notice
here? Well, I don't know about
you. But I noticed that there
are no bullet points here. We
don't have that. So let's get
rid of that. And then of course,
the items are laid out next to
each other. So we definitely
want to be using Flexbox. And
then we want to use flex wrap to
wrap the items around. There is
a little bit of a gap here as
well that we want to include.
Okay, let's get started. So I'm
going to go inside of the UL
first, and I'm going to use list
style type. And I'm going to set
that equal to none. And there we
go. Beautiful, all of the
circles are gone. Okay, what's
next? I definitely want to get
rid of this space right here. I
believe that's the padding.
Let's see. Padding equals zero.
Perfect. Okay, next, let's do
display flex. There we go. Very
nice. Then let's do flex wrap
and set that equal to wrap.
Awesome. Okay, let's keep it
like that for now. And let's go
down here now. And I'm going to
uncomment this first. There we
go. Very nice. Let's get rid of
this line and add some padding
here. How much padding Should we
add? I'm going to try 10 pixels.
First. Let's see how that looks.
Looking pretty good. But I think
I want to increase it to 15.
Actually, there we go much
better. Okay, we also have a
border radius here, of course,
like everything else. So let's
go ahead and add that right
under here. Border Radius. I
also want to make that eight
pixels like the others. So let's
go for eight pixels right there.
Now is there anything we're
missing, as you can see right
here, the items are kind of
cramped together. So we
definitely want to give it some
gap. Let's do gap 10 pixels.
Okay, that's pretty good. But
still, we can see that there was
a little bit of space right here
on the right side for this Red
Bull item. And I want these to
be stretched out as much as
possible. We're gonna use flex
grow for this. So we're gonna
say flex grow equals one, and
that should fix that perfect. Is
there anything else we're
missing here, it's a little bit
difficult to see. But you can
see that the text is not quite
aligned to the center. Let's fix
that text align center. And you
know what, I think this looks
pretty much identical to this
now. Awesome. Now there is one
thing that I also want to
change, I can see that the font
size right here is smaller than
the one up here. I want to see
if it looks better if I change
it the same font size of the
rest. Let's try that up here.
Let's copy it from here, font
size and explicitly define it up
here. So let's set the font size
to 20 pixels. In my opinion,
this looks better. Now of course
it's up to you what you like
better, feel free to make
changes whenever you see fit.
Okay, let's have a final look at
it. Let's run the app. Let's
stretch it out a little bit. Oh
my god, this is looking so good.
This is genuinely looking like
an app that you would download
from the App Store. Is that
crazy? Or am I a little bit
delusional? Don't you think this
looks pretty good? Well, that's
my opinion. Of course, this
definitely looks pretty sweet.
Okay, good job so far. Let's
keep going. Okay, so now our app
is really only missing one
feature. And that's the delete
feature. So we wanted to make it
so that whenever you press on
any one of these items, it is
removed from the cart, meaning
it's removed from the database.
Right. Now, in order to do that,
we need to understand something
very important in software
development. And that's the
concept of a unique ID, let's
have a look at our database. So
here we see all of our items
listed out here inside of the
shopping list. Notice that each
item is listed with a key and a
value exactly the same by the
way as in a JavaScript object.
Now, what is this weird thing
right here? Well, if you notice,
all of these are different from
each other, which means that
it's a unique identifier. Now,
why do we even have to have
these in the first place? Well
think about it. If you want to
delete a specific item from the
database, don't you need to know
exactly which item it is? And
then you might think, well,
don't you already have the name
of the item right here? Yeah,
sure. But what happens if
someone asked the same item
twice the way we've programmed
this, that's definitely allowed.
So we need to have a unique
identifier. And that is why we
have this ID. Now luckily, we're
using Firebase. So we don't need
to worry about creating this ID
for ourselves. Firebase does
that automatically. However, we
do need to figure out a way to
get the ID somehow inside of our
code, because that's the only
way we can tell Firebase to
delete an item for us. Okay,
let's go back to the code. All
right, I'm going to go inside of
here. And I'm going to use the
old console log trick. And I'm
going to say snapshot dot Val.
That's what we started off with.
Right? So let's do that. Again.
Let's run that and see what we
get. Okay, great. Those are all
the items from our database. And
notice here we have both the ID
and the items. Okay, so what
we're doing here is that right
here in the items array, we're
using Object dot values, to
convert those into just the
values. I wonder if there's
another method that we can use
on object that gives us both.
Can you think of anything? If
you can pause right here and put
it in here? I'll be with you in
just a few seconds. Okay, did
you remember it? While remember,
we can use values, but we can
also use keys. Remember, that
will just give us the IDs. Let's
try that by console logging
items array. Let's run that. Now
we get only the IDs. But
remember, there was a third one
called entries. Let's try that
one. Now. What do we get now?
Now we get an array with smaller
arrays inside of it that contain
both the ID and the value. This
is perfect for us. Okay, so what
do we do now? Well, we want to
access these things right inside
of the loop here. So I'm going
to go ahead actually, and do
what I always like to do, which
is make a variable here for the
current item. And in here, I'm
going to say items array, and
then the if element. So we can
use current item here. Okay, so
we got the current item. Let's
see what we get. Now. Let's open
this up. Ah, do you see? Now
this is getting pretty
congested, but we got both the
ID and the value. Okay, this is
looking pretty good. Now I have
a challenge for you, because I
want you to use current item,
but make two new variables, call
it current item ID and current
item value and use current item
to set both of them equal to the
correct values. Okay, pause
here, try it out for yourself.
And we'll be right back.
Okay, I
hope that one well, let's do it
together now. Current item ID.
And that's going to be current
item. Remember, this is an array
with two things inside of it.
What's going to be the ID, well,
that's the first one or rather
the zero of one because we're
dealing with arrays. So I'm
going to say zero in here.
Similarly, we're going to say
current item value. And here
we're going to set it equal to
one. Let's try it out. Now. Id
first let's see how that looks
run. Do we just get the ID
indeed we do. Perfect. Let's do
it for the value now. Run and
now we're back to getting the
value only. Perfect. Now we have
the information that we need.
Well done. Okay, now we have a
little bit of a problem here.
How are we adding a new item to
the shopping list element? Well,
currently we're using innerHTML
with template strings. And while
that works in a lot of simple
cases is not going to work for
us anymore. Why? Because we need
to make it so that we can attach
an event listener to all of
these items, and we need to do
that so that we can run a
function every time the user
clicks on any of these items.
And that's just not possible
this way. So what we need is
Create Element. And you've
actually already seen this,
although very briefly in a
previous scrim. However, in this
one, we're going to dive much
deeper into it. Now I gotta give
you a little disclaimer here,
create element can be one of
those things, that's pretty
confusing to understand, at
least in the beginning, so I'm
going to try my best to explain
it to you in an intuitive way.
Okay, so as you can probably
guess, from the name, Create
Element is a function that lets
you well create an element, of
course, but it's a method that
needs to be applied to the
document object. So you can say
document dot Create Element. And
then you have to make a decision
about which element you want to
make, do you want to make an h1,
a paragraph tag, a div, you can
make anything. And in our case,
we want to make a new list item.
And li That's step one. Step
two, is to give your newly
created item, some text content.
And in our case, that's going to
be the name of the item.
Alright, download step two, the
last step is to place the newly
created element into its parent
element. And in our case, that's
going to be the shopping list
element, the URL. Okay, so let's
go back a little bit and start
with step number one. So I'm
going to go down here. And for
now, we're going to just comment
out this line. And so the first
thing we need to do is to create
a variable, and I'm going to
call it new L. And I'm going to
equal that to document dot
Create Element. Okay, inside of
here, we got to give it what is
it that we want to make? In our
case, we want to make a list
item. That's step one completed.
Okay, so what's step two? Well,
that is put some text between
the tags, right? So let's go
down here and say, Hey, new L, I
want to add some text content to
you. And I want that to be
something we'll fix this later.
We'll just put in a string here
to test it out first. All right,
what is the last step, the last
step is to take this thing that
we just made, and place it
inside of the parent element.
And for that, where is our
parent element? Well, let's go
up here and take a look. That's
going to be our shopping list L
right. So let's copy that. Go
down here. And say, start with
that. And then append. We're
using a method called append.
What do we want to append? Well,
we want to append new L at the
very end. So let's put that in
here. And hopefully, when I run
this now in the mini browser,
it's going to take away all the
names of the items, and is going
to show us a bunch of items that
say something. Let's see if that
works. Let's run this now. And
there we go. It works perfect.
Okay, now, this is where I want
to give you a challenge, pause
here and change the code so that
it actually shows the name of
the items rather than something
for everything. So pause here,
give it a go. And I'll be right
back.
Okay, I hope that
went well. So this is how I
think about it. We already have
item value here as the
parameter, right. So we can just
use this. And we're actually
feeding it up here using the
current item values. So that
should give us what we're
looking for. So let's just go in
here and say Item Value, just
copy it up from here and replace
it down here. And let's now try
to run it, see what we get. And
we get all the items. Amazing.
Okay, so before we end the
scrim, I do want to do one more
thing, because even though we're
getting the value of the items
in here, and that's fine. But we
also would like the ID, because
remember, we want to later on
make it so that we can delete
these items by pressing on them.
And for that we're going to need
the ID. So let's do that now. So
how are we supposed to do that
now? Well, we are getting item
value here, right? But if you
look up here, this is where
we're actually using this
function. And we're feeding this
thing to it. Why don't we just
feed it the current item, which
contains both pieces of
information, right, and then
deal with that down here. Let's
do that now. So let's do current
item, put it in here. And then
we'll go inside of here. And
we'll say let and then let's do
item ID, item, and then zero.
And then we'll say lead again.
And then we'll say item value.
And then we'll say item. And
then of course we want to get
the first one, right. So we can
now delete this. And let's
delete this too. And let's
change this to be just item
instead of item value. And I
think that should work. Let's
run it now. So this, of course,
is still showing the item names,
which is good. Let's change this
now to Item ID just to make sure
that that's working to does that
work and we get them beautiful,
perfect. So I'm going to just
replace it with item value
again. And there we go. Well
done. We achieved a lot in the
scrim. I'll see you in the next
one. Okay, so how do we go about
deleting items from our Firebase
real time database? Let's take a
look at this project that I've
got set up here. So here we have
the Scrimba Times, a
publication running since 2016.
Which is your one stop shop for
Scimba news and beyond? Actually,
I like to go as far as to say
that it's the most trusted
publication in tech. But
unfortunately, that's not true.
See, with the rise of Scimba,
we've been getting a lot more
contributors to the Scimba Times.
And that's a good thing, right?
Well, not always, because
sometimes we end up publishing
fake news, which, of course, is
very bad. And that's not
something we want to stand
behind. So in order to combat
this problem, we've hired fake
news to leaders, yes, we
actually have to hire people to
detect the fake news and delete
it. And so in order for these
people to do their jobs, we need
to create the functionality for
them. So how would that work?
Exactly. So here, I basically
gone ahead and written all of
the code for this, almost all
the code and here you can see
we've got some stories, three
per row. And so we want to make
it so that these fake news, the
leaders can double click any of
these items and delete them from
the database. All right, so
where exactly are we supposed to
write the code? Let's scroll
down here. And writing here's
where we're going to be writing
most of our code. As you can
see, we have double click event
right here, we have a function
that's going to be executed
anytime any of these are
clicked. So what's the first
step? How do we go about doing
this? Let's have a look at the
database. Here we have the
database with all of the stories
and the IDs for it. In this
case, I manually added the IDS
myself just to make it a little
bit simpler for us. But it would
work exactly the same with the
automatically generated Firebase
IDs. Okay, so if we wanted to
tell Firebase, hey, delete this
story right here, we need to
tell it delete the story that
has the ID n s zero. That does
make sense because it's a unique
ID, right? So let's do the first
step, which would just be
literally to console log that
ID. Let's do console log. And
where's that ID? Can we see it
anywhere? There it is. Story ID,
let's try that. Put this in
here, run this. And if we double
clicked any of these, we get the
ID perfect. Does it work for all
of them? Looks like it. Amazing.
All right. So what's the next
step? Well, the next step is a
little bit more tricky, because
in order to delete this story
with this ID, we need to give it
the exact location. So it's not
just the ID. But the fact that
it's inside of the new stories
inside of the database, we need
to give it the full path to
that. So remember, references,
the ref function that we use
before, that's what we're going
to be using. So let's do that
down here. So let's delete this
now. And I'm going to make a
variable for this, let's call it
exact location of story in dB,
and equal that to be ref first,
and then always, we got to
provide it with the database
first. So let's do database. And
then this is where we got to
point to the location. So in
here, we're going to need the
ID. But before that, we're also
going to need this one right
here, the news stories
reference. And so let's let's
put that in there. Let's do new
stories. And then let's do one
of these IDs. Now, let's just
test it out. Now with n s zero,
I see if that works or not, and
S zero, okay, is this by itself
going to do anything? No, this
is just the location, we
actually got to remove it from
the database. And for that, we
need the Remove function, which
is fairly simple to use. So
we're just going to go up here
and import it from Firebase
first remove, let's go down here
again. And we're going to do
remove and we're literally just
going to feed it this whole
thing which contains everything
that it needs. So at this point,
if we run this now and double
click on any of the new stories,
this first story should be
deleted. Let's test that out.
Okay, is the first story of fake
news scramble gets acquired by
Microsoft for 11 billion. That's
definitely fake news. That's way
too little money for scuba. So
we're going to delete that
double click and delete it.
Perfect. It works. Okay, so
what's the last step now? Well,
we're going to make sure that
this ID is just replaced with
whatever ID we're going to be
using for that specific news
story. So let's use template
strings for this, go down here,
make it into a backtick. And
then we're going to say which
one do we want to use? We want
to use this ID right. So let's
just replace it in there. Okay,
hopefully it works now. So let's
run this again and delete all
the fake news. Okay, let's see.
What do we have here? 89 year
old becomes oldest scramble
student to get hired. That's
definitely not fake news. That's
amazing news. scrambler releases
first course entirely made by
AI. Definitely fake news. Let's
double click on that. Elon Musk
welcome 16th child to the world.
That's not fake news. This one
is that fake news now is not
fake news, either. And this is
not fake news, either. I think
we're good now. All right, just
to recap really quickly, the two
main things that we needed to do
was to get the exact location of
the item that we wanted to
remove from the database, and
then just feed that information
to the Remove Firebase function,
and then it takes care of the
rest. And how does it update
instantaneously? Well, remember
we're using that on value
function that takes care of that
right because deal Eating
something from the database also
updates it, which means that on
value gets new information,
which it runs. Okay, I hope that
was clear. I'll see you in the
next one. All right, this is
exciting because we're finally
ready to add the code that
removes items from the database
when we click them in the app.
Okay, so we know by now that the
key information that we need is
the ID of the item in the
database. So let me actually
give you a challenge. Let's
scroll down to this function
right here. And right here is
where I want you to add an event
listener to new L, so that you
can console log the item when
any of these buttons are
pressed. That's the first step.
Pause here, try it out for
yourself. And I'll be right
back.
Good luck. Okay, how
did it go? Let's try it
together. So let's start with
new L. And then we want to add
event listener. We've done this
a million times before. First,
of course, is the event that
we're listening for, that's
going to be a click, and then we
got to write the function in
here. Let's open that up. And of
course, first step is always to
just console log, I personally
find that the easiest to start
with. So what did we want to put
in here though? The ID of the
item? Do we have that already?
Indeed, we do we have it up
here. So let's just copy that
and put that in right here. And
let's run this now to test it
out. Okay, what do we want to
remove from here? Let's remove
the salad. Click, and we got
this console log. Is that the
same one? Yep, that's the same
one right here. P and B is what
it ended on. So we know that's
right. Perfect. Well done. Okay,
what's next. So let's go inside
of here. And this is where I
actually want to give you the
second challenge. And that is
make a lead variable and call it
exact location of item in dB.
And set it equal to ref. That's
the function that we're
importing right up here. We've
already used it here before. And
so we want to use it again,
because we want to get the exact
location of the item before we
can run the Remove function on
it. So you want to set it equal
to this. And then first, of
course, this database as always,
and then there is something and
you are supposed to figure out
what that something is supposed
to be. So pause here, try it out
for yourself, and I'll be with
you in just a sec. Okay, I hope
that went well, let's do it
together. Now, let's go in here
and say exact location of item
in dB, set that equal to ref.
And of course, ref always
requires you to specify the
database. So let's do database.
And then in here, what are we
supposed to put in here? Well,
let's take a look at our
database right now. So right now
we've specified that this is the
database that we're dealing
with. Now what other things that
we need to specify? Well, we
first need to say we're inside
of the shopping list. And
inside, this is the ID that we
want to take away, or this one,
or this one, or whichever one
that we're clicking on, right.
So we're going to start with
this first. So let's go in here,
and I'm going to use backticks.
Let's start with that. And then
do shopping list. And then we
want to do just slash and then
this is where the ID goes. Now
do we have the ID again, we do
have that because we just used
it right up here. Let's just
copy that and put it right in
here course using the dollar
sign in here. And there we go. I
think this is going to work. The
last thing we got to do is to
actually use the Remove
function. And that's where you
come in. Because this is going
to be your last challenge for
this scrim use the Remove
function to remove the item from
the database, pause here, try it
out for yourself. And I'll be
right back. Good luck.
Alright,
so before we can use this
function, we got to import it
from up here. So let's go ahead
and say Remove. And then we'll
go down here. And we just got to
call it like this. And all it
takes is the exact location of
the item in the database, which
we already have. So we're just
going to feed it that
information. And that should
take care of it. So let's run
this now and test it out. Let's
try to delete something, or
should we delete? Let's go ahead
and delete the salad. click and
delete it gone. Perfect, great
job. So I don't know if you've
noticed, but there is a big bug
that we haven't looked at yet.
Try to pause the screen right
here to figure it out. Here's a
hint. It has something to do
with the database items. So try
to remove the items from the
database. I'll see you soon. So
did you spot it? Let's have a
look at it together. So let's
start off by deleting the
database items one by one. Okay,
we're fine so far. Let's
continue
Okay, so now we're down to the
last item. Let's click on it.
Uh, ha, we got an error. Let's
have a closer look at that.
Okay, let's minimize the minimum
browser, we got a huge warning
here. And then it says here
cannot convert undefined or null
to object. Hmm, what's going on
here? Let's close the console.
And I want you to pause the
scrim right here, again, to try
to think about it for yourself.
Before we look at it together.
What is really going on here?
Okay, pause here. And I'll see
you in just a sec.
All right,
so we got to do some detective
work here. First of all, which
code is being executed whenever
we press the button to delete it
from the database? Well, that's,
of course going to be this code
right here, right? Remember,
whenever the database has
changed, this runs every time
but in this case, did it really
run, it gave us an error. And it
did that on the last item.
What's so special about that
one, we'll see when we deleted
the last item, Red Bull in this
case, with it, we also deleted
the shopping list reference. And
when the reference no longer
exists, this odd value function
fails, which means that at that
point, we don't get back a
snapshot, because no snapshot
exists. Okay, so how do we
handle that? Well, I can tell
you that you don't need to
stress about this at all,
because the awesome people of
Firebase, of course, already
thought about this, which is why
they provided us with a method
called snapshot dot exists,
which returns a true or false
boolean value based on if there
is a snapshot or not. Okay, so
armed with this method, I want
to give you a challenge, change
the on value code, so that it
uses snapshot dot exists to show
the items when there are items
in the database. And if there
are no items, it should show the
text, no items here, dot dot dot
yet. Okay, pause here, try it
out for yourself. And I'll be
with you in just a few moments.
Good luck.
Okay, I
hope that one, well, let's have
a look at it together. Okay,
we're using the snapshot method,
which is returning a true or
false value. Whenever I hear
that, I immediately think of an
if statement. Let's start with
that. Let's go up here. And
let's say snapshot dot exists,
okay, this is going to return us
true or false. In the case of
true, that means that there is a
snapshot, which means that there
is at least one item in the
database. So I'm going to open
this thing up here. And I'm
going to put all of this code
inside of there. So let's cut it
from here and put it right in
here. Let's make sure that we
indented properly. There we go.
Now, the else clause, of course,
is going to be when it's false,
which means there are no items
in the database. And so in that
case, what do we want to do?
Well, we want to show the text,
no items here yet. Okay. So
which element is it that we want
to change? Let's go up here is
in that shopping list L That's
the one that's the one showing
all the elements. So let's just
copy that one and put it right
in here. And here, we can just
use innerHTML. That's going to
be the easiest. And let's just
say no items here, dot dot dot
yet. Okay, let's run this now.
And now it shows this perfect.
Now let's test it out by adding
another item here. Let's add
some honey. And there we go.
Beautiful. Let's delete it
again. And we go back. Perfect,
great job. So we have to once
again, take a little pause here
so that I can acknowledge how
awesome you are. Seriously,
you've been doing an amazing
job. And we're so close to being
done. And I can't wait to see
your project when it is done. So
now we only need to add a little
bit of CSS to finish our app.
Now, of course, we'll need to do
a couple more things before
we're finally done. But as far
as the core code for the app is
concerned, this is it. So here's
my next challenge for you add
these two hover effects. When
you hover over the Add to Cart
button and all the items right
here. Another thing is that when
you hover over you see how it
turns into a Mickey Mouse
Cursor. Make that happen, too.
Now let's have a look at the CSS
file because you're going to
need two color hex codes, one
for the add to cart and one for
the items. And I've included
both of them here. Now one thing
I want to do before I let you
start this challenge is Do you
see how these item colors are
black and not dark brown? Let's
change that. I forgot to do that
earlier. There we go. Perfect.
So pause here and make this
happen. Good luck.
Alright, I hope that
went well. Let's start with the
first one. So I'm going to copy
this thing. I'm going to all the
way down here. And under button.
I'm going to say button when
it's the hover state. What do we
want to do? We want to change
the background color to this.
And then we want to do cursor
pointer as well. Let's see if
that works. Hover over and
beautiful works perfectly. Let's
do the same thing for the other
one. Copy it From up here, go
down to the UL. And Li, this is
the one, but we want to do it
when it's hovered. So hover, and
then again, put this in here,
and then again, cursor, and
pointer. That should do it.
Let's see. And it works amazing,
great job. The deeper you get
into development, the more
you'll realize that as a coder,
you literally have to think
about everything, even the
smallest things. Let me give you
an example. Here, we have a
simple project that displays how
many cookies you have given the
cookie monster at any given
moment. So let's run this thing.
So he starts off with an empty
plate. And in order to give
cookies, you just press this
text, here we go, let's give him
a couple. See, everything is
fine when you go slow. But what
inevitably happens when you have
this over to an actual person is
that they start going super
fast. And when you do that, this
happens, see, you start
selecting and D selecting the
text. And in some cases, you can
even select everything like
this. Okay, so how do we fix
this? Well, it turns out that
there is a CSS property that
fixes this, let's go over to the
CSS file, this property is
called user select. And it's
super simple to use, you can
either tell it to select nothing
or everything. So let's go
inside of the h1 and tell it to
select nothing, let's say user
select and then none. Okay,
let's test it out again. Okay,
pressing super fast now see, it
is not able to select the text.
Now, here's the thing about user
select, you can just have it
inside of the h1, or you can
actually put it inside of the
container, or even the HTML in
the body. So at this point, you
can still select and deselect
the image. So what I normally
like to do is to just put this
thing inside of here, and that
takes care of everything. But
just so you know, you can narrow
it down to whatever you like.
Okay, let's try it out once
more.
Beautiful. Okay, time
for a little story. And for this
story, we need to get inside of
the DeLorean. Let's travel back
to the early 2000s. Those were
simpler times, internet adoption
was growing insanely fast. It
was an exciting time to be
alive. There was no YouTube,
Spotify or Facebook. kind of
missed those times. But what
definitely didn't exist back
then was this thing right here?
Nope. Back then, if you wanted
to get on the internet, you
pretty much could only do it
from a desktop computer laptops
existed, but they weren't that
powerful. So for the people
making apps and websites, they
knew that their projects would
be consumed on one type of
display. Simple right? Now let's
get back to our time. How is it
for us now? Well, now we have so
many different devices, it's
hard to keep track of all of
them. And all of them have
different sizes. See the people
that wrote HTML back in the day
didn't think about this. And so
what they decided to do is that
if a website would be shown on a
smaller screen, they would just
shrink the website to fit the
display, like here. And while
this works for monitor displays,
it completely breaks down if
you're on a mobile display,
because this website will look
like this on a phone. Okay, so
how do we fix this? Luckily,
there's a very easy way to fix
this, we just need to explicitly
tell the browser not to shrink
the website, but rather use the
width of something called the
viewport to be the device width
instead. If you'd like to read
more about this, feel free to
click on this link. And so there
isn't really much for me to show
you in this scrim. All we got to
do is go inside of here and
paste in this code. Now I would
like to link to this excellent
YouTube video by Kevin Powell.
If you want a better
understanding of this, I would
recommend you to watch this
video, you can click on this to
open it up in a new tab. And so
that's it for this one. Okay,
we're in the homestretch. Now in
this one, we want to do two
things. Firstly, what can happen
sometimes is that if we press
too fast on the screen, we might
accidentally select a text or
even the image. Now, this is a
common problem that happens. But
luckily, there is a simple fix
for this. In fact, that's my
challenge for you make it so
that you can't select anything
on the app, pause here, try it
out for yourself, and I'll be
right back. Okay, I hope that
went well. I'm gonna go inside
of here and just say user,
select None. And there you go.
See it removed it from here. So
now you can try as much as you
want, but you can't select
anything. Perfect. Okay, what's
next? Well, this isn't something
that we're going to be able to
recreate in the scrambled mini
browser. But what happens is
that unless we add a very
crucial piece of code inside of
our head tag, this app is not
going to look very good on a
mobile device. It's going to be
Ranking, which is something that
we obviously need to fix. Now, I
never seem to remember the exact
code for this. So I always
Google it. So let me actually
give you a challenge right here.
So the challenge is add that
code that makes this app look
proper on a mobile display.
Pause here, see if you can
figure it out. And I'll be right
with you.
Okay, I hope you
got that. So actually went on
Google and found the W three
schools page for it. And I just
copied the code from there. And
I'm going to paste it right in
here. There we go. That's the
one well done. I'll see you in
the next one. Have you ever
noticed that when you use a
browser, every website has an
icon up here? Yeah, well, that's
called a fav icon. And it's
definitely something that you
should spend time on adding to
your website. Okay, so first,
you got to make sure that you
have an icon. This is a cute
image I found that we can use as
an example. And an icon in this
case is really just an image.
Now do make sure that it's a
square image. And also make sure
that it's in a PNG format, I've
included this image for you
inside of the assets folder, so
you can try it out for yourself.
Now once you've got your image
ready, you want to head over to
fab icon.io and press on the PNG
to Ico button, just press this
image to get to the website,
then you want to drag and drop
your image right here. There we
go. It shows up here, then go
ahead and press the Download
button, that's going to download
a zip file, which you can unzip,
and there you'll find all of the
files you'll need. I've already
gone ahead and added those files
to our project here. And now
we're going to need to install
this onto our website, which
really just means to copy this
code and paste it into the head
tag of our HTML. So go ahead and
copy this. And you want to paste
this right inside of the index
dot HTML file and put it under
the title tag. Now, technically,
as long as you have it inside of
the head tags anywhere is going
to be fine. Now, unfortunately,
because of the limitations of
Skyrim, but I can't really show
you how this looks in this grim.
But if you're doing this
locally, you can preview the
website in a browser, and you'll
see the results of it. Okay, now
check this out. This service
gives you some extra options. So
we have some variations of the
image, you'll notice that we
have several image files that
we've downloaded. Now, why is
that? Well, this is just so that
the image quality is the best
that it can be on different
devices. Okay. And then you
might ask yourself, what is this
file right here site dot web
manifest? Well, this is the
magical file that's going to let
us show our icon on the home
screen of our phones, as if our
web app was actually a native
mobile app. But more on that in
another scrim. We're getting so
close to finishing this thing.
Now, we got to make sure that
this app has an icon, so that we
can see it on a tab header in a
browser. But more importantly,
so that we can put that icon on
our phone homescreen to launch
the app. So this is the image
that we'll be using. And I've
actually included this inside of
the assets folder, add to cart
dot png, now we're not going to
use that image directly, we're
actually going to use the
service fab icon.io to generate
all the stuff we need. So open
that up on your side, you're
gonna press this image to open
up the webpage, and then press
on the PNG to ICAO converter,
then you want to just drag and
drop the image here, and then go
ahead and press the Download
button, that's going to download
a zip file, which you want to
unzip, and you'll find all the
files you will need in there.
I've actually already gone ahead
and added those to our project
right here. Now the final thing
we need to do is to scroll down
a bit on the page and copy this
code right here to install this
thing. So let's go ahead and add
that right inside of the head
tag, indent that thing, perfect.
Now, because of how scribble
works, I can't really show you
how this looks. But you'll see
the difference if you're working
locally in your browser. Now you
might notice that there is a
file right here as well site dot
web manifest. We're going to
talk about that in just a little
bit. So remember, when you made
a Chrome extension with ped
earlier in this module, remember
there was a manifest.js file?
Let's pull that up. Now what
exactly is this thing? Well, in
the case of a Chrome extension,
this file tells chrome the
information it needs to hook
this program into Chrome. So
things like the name, the
version number, the icon, the
description. Now all this data
turns into this inside of the
Extensions Manager in Chrome.
Now similarly, there is a web
manifest file that we can make
when we want to turn our web app
into something that looks and
feels like a mobile app. Now the
fancy word for this is a PWA, or
a progressive web app. Now let's
go into the project to take a
closer look. So here I have a
project set up that's called the
cat app. And all it does when
you run it is show a random
picture of a cat. And these
pictures are actually generated
by an AI so all these pictures
are being fetched from this
website called this cat does not
exist.com Okay, so on the left
side, I have a site dot web
manifest file. out here. Now
look at this, this looks
completely messed up. But the
only reason for that is because
there's no spacing and no
indentation. So now I actually
have a challenge for you pause
the screen right here and add
the appropriate spacing and
indentation to make this look
more like a JavaScript object,
something that you're used to.
Okay, good luck. I'll be right
back. All right, I hope that
went well. I'm just going to
paste the solution here. There
we go. This looks much better.
Now what do we have going on
here. So first, we got the name.
And then we got the short name.
Let's go in and say cat app for
both of those cat app. And then
here we have the icons, this is
what's going to pop up on our
home screen. So these are images
that we already have in our
project, of course, generated by
that five icon.io service. And
then we have the theme color.
Now this color right here is
something that you can control.
And let me show you where that
is visible. So that color is
going to be popping up right at
the top here. I haven't turned
to red, so it's easily visible.
So I like to just set this color
to be the background color that
we're using in the app. Okay,
now, what is this background
color? Well, this is the color
that's going to be visible
before the styles for your web
app have been loaded. So if it
takes a while to load them, this
is what's going to be showing,
okay, now finally, what is this
display, it's set to stand
alone. And so this will make the
app look like a standalone
application. So any extra things
that the browser has is going to
take that away. So it looks and
feels like a native mobile app.
Now there's actually a lot more
to the web manifest file than
what I showed you. I can't cover
everything in this scrim, feel
free to click on this page right
here and read more about all the
things that are possible. But
for our use case, this is
plenty. We're finally ready for
the very last step. Can you
believe it? You made it here?
One tiny little thing, and we're
going to be done with this bad
boy. So exciting. Okay, let's do
this. So let's open up the site
web manifest file. And I want to
give you a challenge right here,
pause the scrim and fix this
thing up. So it looks better.
That means add spacing and
indentation. I'll wait for you.
Okay,
I hope that went well. I'm just
going to paste this in. There we
go much better. Let's start
filling in the information here.
So the name of course is going
to be Add to Cart. And let's
just copy this and paste it
right in here. The icons are
already set the theme color we
want to set to the background
color here. So let's just fetch
that from the CSS. Let's go here
and copy this one right here.
We'll put that in for both theme
color. And actually background
color as well. There we go and
display. We want to just keep on
stand alone. And we're finally
done. Can you believe it? You
just finished building your
first app. Oh my God, I hope
you're proud of yourself.
Because I certainly am.
Seriously, take a moment and
give yourself a pat on the back.
Also, make sure to celebrate
this very special moment.
Hopefully you're more excited
than this guy. Seriously,
though. Amazing job. Now the
only thing that's left for you
to do is to deploy your project
using Netlify. And we're going
to do that in the next scrim.
But before we go ahead and
deploy the app, I want to take a
little pause here to briefly
talk about something very
important. And that is that you
should spend a little bit of
time personalizing your app,
because otherwise your app is
gonna look exactly the same as
mine, and probably the same as a
lot of other scoring students.
Now let me show you how easy it
can be to give your app a
personal flair. So this is what
we have right. Now let's change
the image of the cat. That's
looking pretty good. Let's do
another one. Okay, not quite
there yet. There we go. That's
the one. Okay, what about the
font? Let's change it to another
one. Okay, let's keep going. One
more. And there it is. All
right, what about colors? Let's
change it up a bit. Okay,
looking pretty good. How about
adding a little bit of contrast,
there we go. See how just a few
minor changes can make these two
look pretty different. So make
sure to personalize your app so
that you really feel that the
app is showing who you are. And
I know it takes a little bit of
time to do this. But it adds
that little extra you know.
Drumroll please, because it's
finally time for us to deploy
our app to nullify, let's jump
into it right away. So of
course, the first thing we got
to do is to make sure that all
of the project files are inside
of a folder on our machine. So
if you have been following along
with me on scrim by this entire
time, then you want to go ahead
and download the files as a zip
and you probably already know
how to do that. But just in case
you forgot, you want to press on
this button right here. And then
we want to go up here to
download a zip press on that.
And there we go. We're
downloading the zip file on our
machine, then you of course want
to go ahead and unzip that file
on your computer. At which point
you're going to get this folder
with a very weird name where all
of your files are now you want
to go ahead and rename that to
something like add to cart There
we go. Now if you've been
following along on your local
machine this entire time, then
of course, you already have a
project folder. All right, this
part is done. Now, now we need
to head over to nullify, you can
go ahead and press the
screenshot if you want to open
up Netlify on your end, okay, so
I'm going to quickly go up here
and login, I'm going to use
email to log in. But please feel
free to use whichever account is
best for you. And for a lot of
you, that's probably going to be
your GitHub account. Okay, let's
go ahead and log in. And then
you should see something like
this. Now we want to scroll down
a little bit until we see this.
Now down here is where it says
you can drag and drop your
folder, which is exactly what
we're going to be doing. So just
go ahead and drag and drop your
folder here. There we go. Now
it's gonna take a couple of
seconds, and then boom, it's
done. Now, I want to take a
little bit of time to appreciate
this moment, because I've been
deploying my projects for a very
long time now. And I remember a
time when this whole process
used to take several hours,
sometimes even several days. And
we just did all of that with
just a simple drag and drop
truly magical. Okay, anyway, now
our app is finally deployed. Now
we want to go into the site
settings to rename our app. So
just press right here. And then
we want to scroll down a little
bit, there we go. And then press
change site name. So I'm going
to change it from this very
random name to something a
little bit more appropriate.
There we go much better, then go
ahead and press save. Perfect.
And that's it. Now we can go
ahead and press this URL to open
it up in a new tab. Oh, yes,
look at that beauty. That's our
app, which is now live for the
entire world, just like that
amazing job. Now in the next
screen, we're going to do the
very final step, which is to put
this bad boy on our phone
homescreens See you in just a
bit is finally time for us to
put our beautiful creation on
our precious phone. Okay, let's
get right into it. So this scrim
is going to be split into two.
First, I'm going to show you the
steps on how to put your app on
your phone. If you have an
Android, then we'll do the
iPhone. Okay, first thing you
want to do is to open up the
default browser on your phone,
which for Android, of course, is
Google Chrome. Once you've
opened up Chrome, you want to
write down the exact Netlify URL
for your app. There we go. And
there it is. Now go ahead and
press this button to open up the
menu, then you want to go all
the way down to where it says
Add to Homescreen. Press on
that, then it's going to ask you
if you want to change the
display name, I don't want to do
that. So I'm going to just go
ahead and press Add, and boom,
the app is now added to the very
last position of all the apps.
So if you have a lot of apps on
your phone, just got to go to
the very last page. There it is
right there. Once you found the
app, just move it to a more
appropriate position. I'm going
to move it to my first screen.
Perfect. Now let's finally open
it up. Oh my god, do you see it
looks exactly like a native app.
Go ahead and try it out. All
right, let's do it for the Apple
people now. So again, we want to
open up the default browser of
the system, which in the case of
Apple is Safari, then we want to
put in the URL of the app right
here. There we go. And there it
is. And then we want to press
this button right here, it's
going to open up the menu, we
want to go down to where it says
Add to Homescreen. Press on
that. And then it's going to ask
us to set the display name of
this, I'm going to just keep it
to add to cart, press Add and
boom, there we go. There it is.
Okay, now for the moment of
truth. Let's open it up. And
there we go. Do you see it looks
and feels exactly like a mobile
app. And there you have it, that
was the very last step you made
it. You know the best part about
finishing a project being able
to share it with the world. And
that's exactly what I want you
to do if you're comfortable with
it. Of course. Now there are two
platforms that are perfect for
sharing this kind of thing,
Twitter and LinkedIn. So the
first thing you need is to get a
great screenshot of your app
like this one best to do it from
your phone. And if you want to
spend the extra time you can
even make a video or a GIF, then
just write a tweet or post about
you finishing this course. And
showing off your awesome
creation like Brian has done
here with a scrim of project
that he finished on LinkedIn.
This one's from James. And this
one's from Bianca. This is
Oscars finished app on Twitter.
This one's by So Sean. And
here's another one. Now apart
from being able to share your
creations with other people, my
favorite thing about this is
that you're documenting
something that you did in your
life. Imagine how good you're
gonna feel looking back at this
in three, five or 10 years,
especially compared to what kind
of hardcore stuff you're gonna
be working on then. So
definitely share your wins with
the world. And remember to tag
me and scrim by in it that way
I'm gonna get a sweet
notification And I can give you
a like, and a comment to show
you some love. All righty, the
very last thing I want to say is
this. If you have any feedback
at all for me, then I'd love to
hear it. This is chrimbus first
course on Firebase. But we think
it's an awesome technology. And
we'd love to create more courses
going forward. So if you have
anything at all to share on
that, let me know, the best way
to reach me is to tweet at me or
DM me on Twitter. Or you can
also send me a message on
LinkedIn. That's all for this
one. Thank you so much for
listening.
Can you believe it? You did it?
You just finished this entire
project? I am so so so happy for
you right now. Seriously, do
make sure to do something very
nice for yourself after you're
done watching this scrim because
what you've just achieved is no
small thing. Amazing, amazing
job. Okay, we got to do a little
recap before I let you go. So
the first thing we looked at was
import. Now what was that? So we
wanted certain functionality
from Firebase, which we just
imported in the form of
functions. So these are the
things that we imported from
this location. And then here,
this is where all of the code
was. And we only got certain
things that we needed. And then
we covered the Initialize app
function from Firebase, which we
use down here to initialize the
app using the database URL. And
that is just so we have an app
object to work with in our
project, this is what sets
everything up, then we use the
get database function right in
here, when we created the
database object using the get
database function and fed it the
app object that we just made.
This is still part of the setup
that we did. And then we use the
reference function. Remember, in
a Firebase real time database,
everything is a reference. And
so we needed to make a shopping
list reference where all of the
shopping list items would be
saved, then we use the push
function from Firebase, which
was a super simple function
right here to first say that we
wanted to push a new thing at
this reference. And then we just
fed it the value. And that was
it. And then we finally came to
the magical en value function,
which is where we wrote a lot of
the code. So this on value
function just sits here and
listens for changes in the
database. And whenever a change
happens, it gets a new snapshot,
which it uses to run this code
all over again. And so that was
the snapshot, of course. And
then we talked a little bit
about IDs, because in software
development IDs are super
important. And so as we saw in
our real time database, every
single item has to have a unique
ID, then using that unique ID,
we could remove a database item,
which is what we did right here,
we got the exact location of the
item in the database, and then
we just ran the Remove function
on it. We also looked at how we
can transform objects into
arrays, which is what we needed
to do inside of the on value
function, so that we could
actually write a for loop on the
array. That is what we did right
up here. And then of course, we
used Create Element instead of
innerHTML. Because we realized
innerHTML wasn't powerful enough
to do what we wanted it to do,
which is why we wrote this
function, where we created a new
element, and then we gave it
some text content. And then we
made sure that we ran some code
whenever you press on that
button, and then we appended it
to the parent element. And then
of course, we looked at flex
wrap of Flexbox feature, which
let us wrap these elements
around like this. And we also
looked at the GAP feature in
Flexbox, that let us very easily
create this gap between the
items. Then we used user select
to make it so that the user
couldn't unintentionally select
parts of the app, which is just
a much better user experience.
Then we added a crucial line of
HTML to set the viewport, this
one right here, which made it so
that the width of the app would
be correct on mobile devices.
Then, of course, we added a five
icon using that service fav
icon.io. It added all of these
images as well. And then of
course, the final thing was the
web application manifest file
right here, which made it
possible for us to transform our
web application to look like a
native app on our phones. Oh
boy, when you list it out like
that it looks like so much
stuff. And so finally, I'd like
to say well done on completing
this section.